l'homme qui aurait incessamment neuf
premiers centres d'accueil pour les
réfugiés ukrainien on évoquer cet exode
avec bruno il ya quelques instants je me
tourne vers vous
makdah chaude au smic vous vous trouvez
à varsovie en pologne merci d'être avec
nous le président polonais qui a
convoqué ce matin une réunion avec le
gouvernement des commandants militaires
et responsables de différents services
publics de ce pays de l'otan voisins
directs faut-il le rappeler est de
l'ukraine qu'elle est là la posture
adoptée au moment où je vous parle à la
veille de quelques heures de cette
nouvelle nuit un qui se profilent les
politiciens polonais ont condamné l
attaque de la russie comme tous les
autres politiciens occidentaux le
président à jeddah a déclaré que
l'ukraine est victime d'une attaque
armée ce brutal nos pauvres non
provoquées et injustifiée
l'armée polonaise a été mise en alerte
qui semble assez normal dans cette
situation mais cependant la situation à
la frontière ukrainienne avec le pen est
stable mais il me sens il nous semble
que ceux qui quittent maintenant le
crâne viendront à la frontière ils vont
se présenter à la frontière dont
quelques heures peut être demain dans
être dans après demain on attend aussi
de refuge et de graines qui vont arriver
en pologne 1 la pologne qui s'est dit
aussi prête à accueillir quelques
milliers de blessés a ainsi besoin à
l'instar du président estonien qu'on
avait vu se présenter physiquement en
personne à kiev il ya quelques jours aux
côtés du président zelensky on voit le
voisin polonais faire faire preuve d'un
soutien sans faille à aujourd'hui oui
bah le gouvernement polonais a assuré
les ukraniens que qui vu qu'ils peuvent
en fait venir en pologne si jamais ils
cherchent un endroit safe même s'ils
n'ont pas de passeport juste avec deux
documents qu'ils ont de leur pays mais
aussi ils sont bien non c'est qu'ils
sont prêtes à l'aider
le les gens blessés au niveau médical
ils vont même organisé en train en fait
qui va aller chercher les gens blessés
de guerre pour le ramener en pologne et
le soigner ici un dernier mot ce que ce
qu'on est en train de vivre à l'est de
l'europe aujourd'hui
l'europe qui vit les heures les plus
sombres depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale évidemment ça fait
remonter à la surface de douloureux
souvenirs on imagine aussi pour les
polonais quel est l'état d'esprit des
polonais aujourd'hui comment ont-ils
vécu
ces scènes ces images qui ont choqué
évidemment toute l' europe 1 ce matin je
pense que les polonais sont tout à fait
juste choquée mais en même temps ils
font preuve d'une grande solidarité le
groupe dead qui ont été créés pour aider
les autres pendant le confinement ou
pendant la crise avec la frontière avec
la russie
maintenant sont utilisés pour organiser
l'aide aux ukrainiens il ya des gens qui
m'aiment sauf en fait qui disent qu'ils
peuvent aller chercher les gens qui ne
peuvent pas rester en ukraine parce
qu'ils sont très faibles ce sont deux
des 11 pour les enfants donc il ya un
grande solidarité en ces moments on peut
en pologne et j'ai l'impression que les
polonais se
concentre sur sa ils veulent par en fait
restée
inutile à d'une façon ils veulent
vraiment aider les ukraniens
pays voisins qui avec qui on ressent en
fait cette sentiment de très attaquées à
cause de l'histoire aussi merci beaucoup
à magdalena chaude ovni qui remercie en
direct donc 2